hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zur vierten 4134
vierten folge christmas kraft wir haben
heute das thema am start von euromed
9000 was schenkst du dieses jahr seiner
kleinen schwester und das war ganz
witzig habe erst gedacht dass meine
schwester ist geschrieben hätte all
ihren youtube account und hat mich auch
abonniert allerdings heißt die anders
ich werde nicht verraten das wollte die
nicht
und naja europe schreibt was ich meiner
schwester denn dieses jahr schenke und
ich dachte halt es ist die dass wir uns
weiter habe ja schon gesagt und der bau
vorschlag kommt von mate also merzig
wird mein vater sagen das heißt mit 31
03 2010 könnte ist einen adventskranz
bauen also dass das die letzte folge war
ja auch dann wieder überall so
zweistellig ich dachte eigentlich die
kursmuster folgen relativ kurz werden
weil wir nicht im great big band geht es
eine relativ schnell wenn ich sachen
paul borders hatte ich einen krassen
bass oder
schade ist schon krass naja jedenfalls
habe ich mir kraft ich baue jetzt jedoch
ein wenig den adventskranz der
museumstag holz gucken wartet das ist
sport das schon ganz gut
das inspirierte slaves ich weiß nich
kloster solchen ganz anderes nehmen
was könnt ihr schon daneben
was kann ich denn dann nehmen ich
brauche irgendwann dort gestellt
ich nehme einfach eine touch oder wald
kloster in klostern sieht nicht so schön
aus aber warum ist denn da kloster oder
doch doch ganz schön aus ich würd sagen
wir bauen einfach mal direkt hier hin
und naja ich fange man direkt
anzuquatschen und zwar ist das bei mir
immer der schwester immer so wir
schenken uns eigentlich nie so wichtige
sachen gegenseitig also wenn das nie so
wirklich besprochen dass wir uns sachen
schenken beziehungsweise sagen und soll
die gegenseitig was von schenck meine
schwester hat damit angefangen hat mir
dann auch zu weihnachten was gekauft
sondern so eine itunes geschenkkarte vor
23 jahren den vor drei jahren war es
ungefähr
als simin eltern dann auch etwas gekauft
oder gebastelt hatte mir das hat auch
gekauft und ich fand das sondern ganz
cool habt dann ihr danach dann auch noch
was gekauft von der gamescom habe ich
glaube ich sagen so ein dings
mitgebracht so ein komisches figürchen
von lilo & stitch oder so ich weiß es
hat gar nicht genau
jedenfalls hat sie sich darüber gefreut
blabla wahrlich schon gut nur die sache
ist die dass es immer so die sache ist
ich weiß halt nicht genau was sie sich
wünschen wenn ich sie frage dass auch
dort etwas entsteht 28 soja und pc in
der liste ok
den kann ich dir wohl nicht kaufen so
ist halt alles nicht so einfach wie das
bei erwachsenen ist die kamera relativ
schnell glücklich machen wenn man
einfach mal abend die schnauze halten
sie auch schon gewinner spaß
da kann man dann mal eine weihnachts cd
kaufen oder irgendwie sowas aber dieses
jahr was schenke ich denn da meiner
schwester ich denke ich werde ihr
habe ich mir noch gar keine gedanken
gemacht die frage die auch gerade ich
habe wohl einfach ausgesucht hat zur
frage jetzt bin ich eine aufnahme stimmt
was wollt ihr überhaupt schenken was ich
behalt mal kurz den schnee dann kann ich
den nachher drauf packen egal
themenübergreifend ich fange mal ganz
anders bauen und so hält die sollte
hinlegen er so ok dann machen wir das so
danach das dings drauf hat gar nicht wie
baut man den sonnen kreist jetzt hier
sage ich mal so ich brauche mir das mal
gerade einfach ich hoffe ihr wisst
ungefähr wie das hier aussehen soll
also hier soll nachher noch so komische
dings darum lautet ich versucht euch das
ein wenig zu demonstrieren
anhand dieser kleinen dieses kleinen
prototyps hier sag ich mal
so soll das nämlich nachher aussehen so
und dann kommt hier ein bloß tor auf und
da kommt noch eine fackel
ich kann keinen fackellauf lost
bescheuert und da kann ich hier der
teufel lässt sich vielleicht ein glas
oder soll ich dann lieber fackeln nehmen
glaub ich mache das dann so nah oder
fern
ich weiß es nicht
ich glaube fackeln sie doch schön raus
ja ich glaube in ihren fackeln und los
mach ich das jetzt eigentlich besonders
dinge also ich denke einfach ich werde
ihr dieses jahr sein itunes
geschenkkarte die kann man ja immer gut
gebrauchen oder weil ich meinen die hat
jetzt ok kann man doch ein
könnt ihr mir eigentlich mal die
kommentare schreiben butt kann der lukat
seiner schwester schenken
die heißt übrigens ich sag ich dir noch
nicht ob die habe ich ja schon mal
gesagt was könnte ich dir denn schenken
das überlebt ist bin ich ein echter
verzweifeln
das was wünschen sich denn so kinder
oder mädchen im alter von 13 jahren beim
abiball habe ich das 1 2 3 4 5
ich denke also die macht gerne ballett
und so aber ich habe schon überlegt
ballettschuhe hat sie als neue bekommen
und wenn ich irgendwas ich könnte ihn
schal von von zara oder ihn wie sowas
kaufen
das wer bestimmt was für sie na ja ich
würde sagen mir fällt schon was ein
aber jetzt auch nichts teures also ich
finde an weihnachten kommt es darauf an
dass man sich überhaupt verschenkt und
nicht den preis also untereinander fest
der liebe und die stadt ja meine mädchen
mit mails mittels nimmt das übrigens
bezieht nicht so ernst mädels gibt es
viele die da irgendwie meinen ja du
nennst mich mädels ist endlich warten
hier
ich bin junge du solltest du mal lernen
jetzt begreifen und wo es ist ein scherz
na gut das nur kurze am rande ja keine
ahnung oder ich könnte ja auch im film
schenken also ich weiß dass ich meiner
mutter ich hoffe mal die wir dieses
video nicht sehen
seiner mutter werde ich wahrscheinlich
eine cd schenken
und das blöde ist einfach dass meine
mutter jetzt schon am 5
dezember also genau morgen hat sie
geburtstag und da wollte ich eigentlich
eine cd schenken das heißt ich kann
nichts weihnachten natürlich keine cd
geschenkt weil sie die ja dann schon
bekommen hat sage ich mal
das heißt da muss ich mir noch was
überlegen was da der mache und ohne wird
der kranz ist fertig und wir sind alter
wesen schon wieder bei sieben minuten
ohne witz ich frag mich echt wie wie
schaffe ich es denn hier die ganze zeit
so zu quatschen pause und komische kranz
und bin in sieben minuten das schaffen
anderen paar sekunden na gut ich würde
sagen wir bauen auch noch ein bisschen
wir könnten da theoretisch in der mitte
die kandidaten der mitte bauen
ich mache einfach jetzt holz sind hier
sollen so hatte das oder das oder das
nein auch ich hasse dieses so eins von
diesen drei sorten die was ich habe eine
sorte vergessen glaube ich also das war
es dann eigentlich auch schon erstmal
mit dieser erfolgreichen auch drinnen
boden hin und viele leute haben das
prinzip immer noch nicht verstanden
sie fragen mich immer noch wie man in
sachen gewinnen kann bei mir hier in
christmas kräftig dazu sagen leute
hey ich hab noch gar keiner hat gewonnen
dass er vor der asche
also leute mal ganz ganz ruhig es läuft
so ab dass er mir in der woche also das
heißt in der woche ihr dürft mir vom
montag
also was hätten auch was habe ich
eigentlich dürfte mir jetzt vom ersten
wo die erste folge raus kam bis zum
neunten dürften die kommentare witzige
geschichten schreibe sagen geschichten
die ihr ich damals nie das passt sich
das holz die euch zum lachen bringen das
sieht doch gut aus
das liegt das noch besser aus
geschichten die euch sage ich mal zum
lachen bringen bzw
die müssen ja nicht nur euch passiert
seitenhalt doch eigentlich sollten schon
euch passiert sein weil sonst das
editorial im internet gucken er witzige
geschichten die euch im die euch
passiert sind an weihnachten da waren
schon übels wieder witzige sachen dabei
wie zum beispiel dass da welche eine
schneeballschlacht gemacht haben und der
einer die anderen gestört während die
ihnen tee getrunken
und dann wurde der andere dann
ausgezogen im schnee und wird dann
einfach zurückgelassen und das war
grundsätzlich hat er mit hat der typ mit
auch in die kommentare geschrieben und
ich lese mir das echt alles durch und
sucht dann die besten sachen aus einem
haus zu so dass wir nie richtig geil
das habe ich schon abgespeichert also
ich suche mir dann immer so aus den
folgen so ein paar lustige geschichten
raus bei geschichten in denen jetzt
ersten zehn folgen und die welt dann am
zehnten sage ich man alle vorlesen in
der folge und die sollen dann bitte die
werden dann alle von minecraft
angeschrieben und bekommen dann ihr
geschenk dazu geteilt
also das ist der kranz wenig gebaut hat
für diese folge schaffen wir eventuell
400 likes für diesen kranz wm letztes
mal übels viele lecks geschafft also die
erste folge mittlerweile 2500 likes die
zweite folge habe ich auch schon über
1000 also das ist richtig richtig krass
wie aktiv ihr wirklich seit das finde
ich richtig richtig richtig geil dritte
folge habe ich noch gar nicht richtig
für jetzt verfolgt die den letzten tag
naja jedenfalls würde ich mich halt die
beiden daumen hoch freuen
facebook twitter etc ist in der
beschreibung auch texture pack unsere
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
freunde und kommt wahrscheinlich
kommentare schreiben nicht vergessen